so have you ever met a parent who had a
child seriously so the other thing about
this I think that is missing in this
discussion is it it appears to me from
the responses and from the further
discussion is that people are not
fully aware of mental illness it seems
like mental illness is being discounted
you know people are okay with mastectomy
if it's cancer physical illness but
mental illness seems to still take a
back seat as not being real and
um it's like they they discount it like
you could just get therapy for this
mental illness or you could just you
don't need a medical intervention for
this mental illness it's not mental
illness in general just doesn't seem to
be taken as seriously as physical
illness so people seem to be okay with
it in one instance as long as it's
cancer physical you know then it's okay
for a young adolescent to get you know
if a young adolescent girl develops
breast cancer you'd be fine with a
mastectomy at that point but if she's
developed a serious case of gender
dysphoria where she's trying to commit
suicide on a regular basis but the
number of kids the number of people who
actually have gender dysphoria is beyond
minuscule right right very low so right
very very it's point five percent in
adults right and even then even then
even then I would very heavily caution
against a Top surgery because of the
complications because of the fact that
it's not reversible and because we know
so many people that as adults do
Transition and then what do you do you
try to piece your life back together in
some way without a whole body so I'm
somebody that also by the way would say
you had brought up in the I was trying
to follow the chain of people but you
had brought up like a nose job you might
brought up which is awesome and nose is
a is not like a cosmetic part of your
face right I mean that is an actual
organ that has a function and yet young
girls are getting nose jobs all the time
right so it is it is a little bit
different
um because well if you remove breasts
you completely remove the functionality
right you remove breasts you can't
breastfeed isn't a they're gone but a
lot of women don't breastfeed you get a
lot of women do breastfeed but a lot of
women don't true so but a lot but they I
mean so you're the real ramification I
mean ultimately I mean it is
so is a nose job I mean that's my point
on bringing that up is it is you can't
parallel a nose job removal of breasts
though I mean listen I and I say this as
somebody who I would not advise a parent
to get a kid breast implants a nose job
or any of that either would I I would
not like wait till you're 18 years old
for many reasons even then I would tell
them not to right but for many reasons
because with noses your noses are still
growing and you grind up sometimes with
a distortion
um with breast I'm not an advocate for
breast implants I personally don't think
that it's healthy um we actually have a
guest coming on in a few weeks that are
going to talk about autoimmune diseases
related to that yeah so I'm very non
like I'm not interested in all those
procedures as a human but do you think
that a parent should be prevented from
allowing their kid a nose job or breast
implants you know there are 16 17 year
old girls get breast implants well I
think that there's a problem so should
they be prevented I think there's a
problem with doctors that do those
procedures on young people
there's an ethical problem that needs to
be yeah I agree I agree in some in some
circumstances I mean there's there's I
remember a girl in my high school that I
mean she got a nose job in the eighth
grade she was very young she had
numerous issues because her nose did
grow that doctor should not have a job
or a license I mean so there are doctors
doing things and we see that right if
you've learned anything in the last two
years you've learned that just because
you have a lab coat doesn't mean you're
an expert sure so I think it's tackling
it from two perspectives it's like there
are there are actual doctors in this
industry either in a money making
Enterprise that are not looking out for
what's best for people and are making
bad decisions and you also have this new
desire to be like part of the woke Club
where there's a rush it's just take a
pause you know when you're gonna do
something like a medical procedure there
needs to be a pause there's always a
risk there's always a consequence that's
not like let me put my child into
therapy and let's figure this out if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]